neben das ist bisschen ungewohnt aber
hey neu ist dann noch vors viel gemacht
dieser [ __ ] services kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft und heute spiel mit klicks
sowie games und manche von euch erinnern
sich vielleicht noch ich habe gestern
nacht um 12 gefragt wer mir fragen
schicken könnt zum zur ergänzung des
videos von gestern ihr habe ich dann
aber doch nicht gebraucht
ich wollte aber nicht unbeantwortet
lassen deswegen machen wir jetzt dieses
games video als kleines kriminell video
um euch die gelegenheit zu geben dass
die verantwortung werden nicht offen
stehen bleiben denn dass ich einfach
nicht cool und dazu habe ich jetzt heute
im hintergrund die julia maria sehr
schön die diese tage hier in berlin
plant einem einer zumindest temporären
zimmergenossen ist und ja uns einfach so
mit der bude hilft auch beim putz und so
weiter sofort wieder schloss wie finde
ich berlin sehr gut muss ich sagen ich
habe in berlin super start gab leute
hätte nicht die notwendigkeit mehr ist
hier noch eine große wohnung zu suchen
weil ich bei einem meiner kollegen
unterkommen konnte
ich wurde hier relativ warm empfang lage
müssen das was machen an der bruder aber
das nicht so das große drama ist mir
lieber als dass man irgendwo eine fremde
wohnung zieht die iso anonym ist ich war
ich übrigens schon mal davor weil ich
hier ein video geschnitten habe während
des roadtrips das heißt ich kannte die
wohl auch ein bisschen und so war das
alles ja also bisschen freundlicher der
einstieg ich hatte auch ein fahrrad was
ich heute morgen benutzen konnte auf dem
weg zur arbeit und so was hat man
einfach nicht immer alleine in eine
fremde stadt kunden da niemanden kennt
und ich würde im allgemein sagen so die
tatsache dass ich ein paar leute kannte
hat mir die den ein stück echt
erleichtert ich habe jetzt überhaupt
keine ein fremdes gefühl oder kein
heimweh so wie man das manchmal anfang
hat wenn man in so einer stadt umzieht
bei mir ist einfach alles entspannt muss
ich sagen ich hab mich heute selbst
gewundert ich setze auf dem fahrrad
irgendwie komisch aber es ist sehr
entspannt also berlin bisher
absolut gut aus wenn meine heimat fehlen
vielleicht die beschaulichkeit dass ich
doch ganz witzig so ich habe kurz mal
den hier auch hier staunten was wird man
meiner heimat fehle ich weiß nicht meine
heimat ist halt deutlich an zumindest
auf meine familie wohnt das ist deutlich
sauberer vom gesamtbild her ich würde
sagen die leute sind freundlich
es ist im allgemeinen ein bisschen
heimelige also man läuft durch die
straßen fühlt sich immer zu hause
hier in berlin ist halt so und ich finde
zumindest äußerlich dass die hier
teilweise viele viele frauen überlegen
ganz wenig auf sie achten irgendwie also
extrem verlottert angezogen
wenn ich das mal so sagen das ist
zuhause anders vielleicht das gibt es in
sich so an ich weiß ich bin nicht so up
to date ich bin erst zwei tagen über die
leute verzeiht mir das ist mir heute
aufgefallen
aber ich mein leben das eine können sie
sich so wohl fühlen klar denn dann mit
es die finger von lassen aber egal wo
wie kann es sein dass sie nur noch weg
hatte biss sie sehen kann das sein dass
das vielleicht ein scheiß nur noch bei
kaster
ja er hat nur noch weg wirklich zusammen
leute ist das geil erstmal ein hacker im
deathmatch wie sinnlos warum nur noch
berlin co sgv okay jetzt weiß ich warum
wir ihn einfach nicht weg sein kann ja
vielleicht hinterher ein hacker im kurs
von der wahrscheinlichkeit ausgespielt
alter faktisch muss auf findet so
zumindest bringt nichts läuft einfach
weiter
soll ich noch nirgendwo beleidigend weil
der hektar oder so wenn ich konzentriert
einfach mal besuchen zu können
ja genau
also ich kann jetzt den bogen nur für
damage nehmen
ich kann den bogen nicht zum noch
wegnehmen das ist bisschen ungewohnt
aber hey jetzt hat er noch viel gemacht
dieser [ __ ] dreckiger hacker so leute
damit endet diese hunde schreibt ihr
noch irgendwas wir gehen auf jeden fall
in die nächste runde hat er wie frech er
schreibt auch noch die junge ohne witz
gibt leute die sind echt preis ok
nächste runde zu runde nummer zwei leute
und mit roma zwar auf die nächste frage
also nicht hätten wie ich in solcher am
liebsten
ich muss sagen das sushi teilweise
richtig gut schmecken wenn man es
einfach mit den fingern ist und ich
glaube das macht man traditionellerweise
auch so nice abend schön kleiner lag
immer also ich glaube dass im text
objektes spinnt ein bisschen teilweise
habe ich das ein bisschen hilft die
gelegt die nicht so schön sind
kurzum alle gäste anziehen kriegsschiff
erschwert mein lieblingsbuch also mit
den fingern ist es sehr lecker aber auch
mit den stäbchen finger aber eher selten
freundlich im restaurant das ist einfach
wahr und zivilisiert auch hier wurde
wahrscheinlich sie draußen
wahrscheinlich ist hier hinten
das sieht so abgeschieden aus natürlich
war klar und hier war noch keiner
wunderbares manstein schwert mein
lieblings sushi
ich mag so bisschen diese bisschen
kunstvollen inside out rolls oder so
sehr gerne aber auch die klassischen
shaqiri nimmt man die regierung agiere
meisten karten stehen dafür mit schalke
also dieser reis stieg auf dem dann oben
dass der fisch drauf liegt wissen was
ich meine also nicht die rollen sondern
hallo hätten vermehrt donnerstag gleich
down ist noch schön mit dem angelbeck
bridgewater frage damit beantwortet oder
so die erste linie aus einem rap-song
der mir einfällt
ich habe so viele rap-songs rap ist
nicht wirklich warme dusche job ist er
los
das geht mir grad im kopf weil ich das
auch heute bisher gehört habe eine dukic
mich nicht hier gratis pizza und
dungeons nächste frage
ich stehe da oben drauf der politik
deutlich 45 grad invertiert mit aber
november richtiger linse drin ansonsten
sich rechts nicht zur flüchtlingspolitik
was steht er noch dabei das ist super
flüchtlingspolitik super für diesen fall
okay nicht frei war ich besser auch
schon zwei jahre dabei weiß er sie
finden diese fischerei ist richtig krass
geworden
das war damals noch nicht so heftig also
und es gibt jetzt sehr viele leute die
irgendwie so content machen der sich
nicht verlesen nicht groß von den konten
anderer unterscheidet da würde ich mich
aber auch mit anschließen
so aber ist es eine veränderung oder gab
es damals schon schwierig zu sagen
auf jeden fall sagt kann ich sagen dass
ich nicht will dass hier bald auf mich
ein schlag aber sehr gerne würde ich ihr
abstand natürlich of my little butterfly
lovers junge als ob wie die spieler
haben gesehen wie schnell er sich
umgedreht hat mich runter gelockt hat
water for kalter ok aber in einer
untergeht noch runde am ural leute habe
ich den fahrgästen zu zufrieden die
antwort nicht gefallen
ja es sind halt paar leute wie co groß
geworden also muss ich wirklich das
vielleicht anders und das ist eben ein
bisschen feindlicher geworden die
atmosphäre habe ich das gefühl dass das
würde auf jeden fall auch noch sagen die
atmosphäre als feindlicher früher war
das irgendwie viel viel wärme viel
entspannter die leute waren freundlicher
zueinander
ich weiß nicht was das verändert hat
wahrscheinlich waren sie half menschen
nicht keine ahnung ich kann sich sagen
aber das würde ich doch mal sagen dass
ich dir jetzt gehst du dann erhalten
nicht mal eine waffe sehr schön nächste
frage wo ich würde auf jeden fall
fliegen
ich würde fliegen ich würde die fliegen
in der ich würd fliegen ich würde mich
unsichtbar machen und ich würde menschen
heilen oder in deren köpfe schauen
menschen heilen
ich würde menschen heilen auf jeden fall
gar nicht um irgendwie menschen
unsterblich zu machen aber es gibt aber
viel zu viele menschen die zu früh
sterben und das muss nicht sein wenn man
da wie highland eingreifen könnte das
wäre schon ganz geil also die drei
fähigkeiten fliegen und sichtbar
unsichtbar machen und heilen
jetzt vertritt professional all der hau
rein kommt also in meiner zukunft habe
ich vor in der nahen zukunft habe ich
vor zu schlafen das jetzt wieder nach 11
ich möchte heute mal um 12 uhr ins bett
gehen damit ich morgen nicht todes
verpennt wieder bei der arbeit auf
kreuze nahe zukunft ansonsten ich möchte
weiter studie nehme ich mein studium
beenden sofern es mit meiner uni nicht
aus mysteriösen gründen den bach runter
geht möchte ich auf jeden fall mein
studium beenden
ich möchte nach meinem studium nach köln
ziehen noch ein zweites studium starten
nochmal grundständigen bachelor
vielleicht in psychologie oder bisschen
was wo ich mehr nach fand studiere weil
meine jetzige studienwahl schon so ein
bisschen na ja gar nicht so krass also
das war nicht so nach dem motto womit
kann ich gut geld verdienen aber es war
so nach dem motto ich weiß nicht was sie
machen soll und dann war's halt zufällig
denn es hat auch jeder andere sein
können mittlerweile komme ich gut damit
klar so beziehungsweise ich habe ja noch
mal gewechselt also ganz so einfach ist
es nicht ich hab mich erst für den
anderen springern beworben nämlich
kommunikationswissenschaften
da bin ich von
kommunikationswissenschaften zu
wirtschaftswissenschaften gewechselt
komplex aber auf jeden fall der punkt
ist ich möchte in köln wohnen drei tagen
in berlin vielleicht sie diesen drei
monaten anders aus aber köln ist nach
wie vor eine große kleine liebe dafür
dass ich noch nicht so viel zeit
verbracht hat mag ich die stadt sehr
ja und dann irgendwann fängt dann wohl
auch die arbeit an und aber ich möchte
nach wie vor selbstständig sein das echt
mein traum ich merke dass die heute in
den ersten beiden arbeitstagen leitl
fest
vor allem wenn man für andere leute
arbeitet das ist einfach das ist
wirtschaftlich dummen leute das wird das
sagen also es wirtschaftlich einfach
vollkommen humbug für andere zu arbeiten
wenn man die möglichkeit hat die arbeit
in sich selbst investieren
man arbeite ehrlich für den profit für
andere der anderen so allemann arbeitet
den anderen die tasche und die geben
einen bruchteil dessen was man für sie
erwirtschaftet ob das für einen sinnvoll
ist muss jeder genau überlegen würde ich
sagen aber wenn sie mir die möglichkeit
bietet werde ich auf jeden fall
selbständig ein ok ja noch ne frage das
war jetzt eine sehr ausführliche antwort
mein lieblings mutter ist und welche
person will ich mal kennenlernen
diese harmonie
nein das mache ich diese oder aber wie
viel leben hast du noch nicht mal die
der jazz sehr gerne aber oho zwei herzen
in renn renn renn renn renn renn noch
was habe ich etwas vergessen
ja nein ich weiß ich hab ich das
vergessen zu den fragen passt okay die
todes startet mitte überleben ich möchte
gerne mal nach honolulu auf hawaii sehr
gerne aber einfach ich nachher wer
möchte da geht nicht um die stadt
sondern mehr um der territorien okay das
war's dann den fragen und tipps wenn ich
da hat mir am besten gefallen
köln das war's für heute haut rein
macht's gut und und dann kann er ja die
ist vielleicht eine beschreibung
verlinkt